also das ist meine meinung ich will
jetzt auch keinen angreifen der dazu
mein video gemacht hat ich weiß nicht
wie ihr das seht aber englisch was geht
ab jetzt willkommen beim neuen video
wie ihr vielleicht schon seht ich bin
jetzt nicht so zu hause also nicht nicht
die gewöhnliche umgebung weshalb sonst
in videos ist und zwar bin ich in
österreich bisschen ski fahren so auch
wenn das wetter nicht ganz so geil ist
es regnet und schneit gerade ein
bisschen draußen also ich will gar nicht
eingeladen auf jeden fall bin ich halt
nicht zu hause so aber es werden
natürlich trotzdem videos kommen und wir
starten auch direkt heute ist dienstag
hat mir gedacht komm ich ferien macht
einfach mal ein video mehr oder halt
dann wieder rockers also es kommen viele
videos weil ich bock ab und ja ich habe
mir wirklich überlegt ob ich das thema
jetzt wirklich mal ansprechen weil ich
ich krieg das war sehr oft mit dass ich
gefragt werde
mach doch mal bitte das und das aber ich
denke mir dazu immer was und macht halt
nicht also mir schreiben nicht so viele
leute ja bitte mach doch mal was jungs
ein mädchen lieben ich denke mir das als
erstes immer das thema ist schon total
ausgelutscht also das haben schon so
viele leute gemacht aber ich will jetzt
wirklich so war was dazu sagen weil das
ergibt eigentlich alles gar keinen sinn
viele von euch wissen wahrscheinlich
ich hab mal zwei videos dazu gemacht so
was ich an mädchen total eklig wenn du
also los bei mädchen
dabei denke ich mir so ja dazu kann man
ein video machen weil der großteil der
jungs hat wirklich so so so die gleichen
logos aber dann hingegen den video zu
machen was jungs oder was wir halt an
mädchen lieben ist finde ich dass das
kann man gar nicht beurteilen also das
ist meine meinung ich will jetzt auch
keinen angreifen der dazu ein video
gemacht hat ich weiß nicht wie ihr das
seht aber ich denke mir dazu so stellt
euch mal vor ich würde euch jetzt hier
fünf sachen auf den tisch hauen und dann
würdet ihr euch genauso verhalten wie
ich jetzt sage jetzt nur als beispiel so
ist ja eigentlich das ist ja so der sinn
dieser videos ich meine die mädchen die
sich das angucken die gucken sich das ja
an um halt das auch dann meistens
umzusetzen man sucht ja nicht umsonst
nach so was das heißt ich will das jetzt
mal so als beispiel fünf dinge nennen
was ich halt an mädchen toll finde was
ich an mädchen toll finde und
mädchen würden sich dann halt diese
diese mädchen die das video dann gucken
die würden sich dann alle so verhalten
weil sie denken jeder junge ist halt so
aber das sind eigentlich überhaupt nicht
ich meine ihr würde euch dann alle so
was von verstellen weil ich sage euch
irgendwas und das macht ihr dann halt
das ist ich will es gibt natürlich auch
sehr viele die es nicht machen will aber
man guckt sich ja normalerweise dieses
video haben um halten sich so und einen
jungen so bisschen so was ihr wisst
schon was ich meine
das resultat davon wäre das halt alle
mädchen dann 40 gleich werden und das
ist total das was ich halt nicht will
das ist ja total langweilig stellt euch
mal vor allem mädchen wenngleich weil
sie den youtube video gesehen haben wie
man jung was was jungs halt so ein
mädchen lieben ich kann euch sagen was
alle jungs ein mädchen neben seit süß
und so wie ihr selbst auswärts schon
weil wenn man sich jetzt ein
youtube-video reingezogen hat und sich
dann wirklich so verhält dann merkt auch
jeder junge direkt dass ihr halt nicht
normal seid ja das ist auf jeden fall
jetzt mal meine meinung ich wollte dazu
einfach mal das sagen was ihr wirklich
davon denke ich habe ja auch schon so zu
dem anderen thema was so ähnlich ist ein
video gemacht aber damit will ich auf
keinen fall erreichen dass ihr euch dann
alle so verhalten weil ist total das
gegenteil von dem das ist einfach nur
meine meinung und fertig altweil mehr
zeit aufgefallen
es gibt viele menschen die lassen sich
von so you tube videos ziemlich ja das
verändert die halt obwohl das eigentlich
meiner meinung nach nicht sein sollte
ich denke ich könnte mich da ein
bisschen verstehen auf jeden fall so
viel dazu ich hoffe das video hat euch
ein bisschen gefallen falls ihr euch
schreibt die kommentare oder lassen doch
nach oben da würd mich sehr freuen
und ansonsten ist hier installiert wie
immer könnt ja mal vorbei schauen wir
auf der linken seite geht es weiter mit
meinem letzten you das war hier
irgendwas so zum zum tag sonntag mag ich
nicht so ganz
warum schaut euch an und hier auf der
anderen seite geht's weiter mit
ich habe gerade überlegt einfach mal
logos bei mädchen 2 könnt ihr mal
abschicken
das ist wirklich so was ich will gar
nicht gar nicht mehr länger lagern
und ja ich wünsche euch noch einen
schönen tag wir sehen uns donnerstag
wieder da kommen zwei videos einzel
meinem bruder und eigentlich noch mal
mit einem bruder auf unserer neuen
channel
den link dazu packt ihr euch natürlich
auch in die beschreibung und hat bei
leute